صباح النور تتمثل هذه العقبه بحسب ما يرد
طباعه عن عبر وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
اولا وفي الكتاب الذي ارسله باليمين اتناه
عندما طلب
مهله التمديد لاسبوعين للرئيس هرسك منحها
10 ايام تتمثل في الشروط التعجيزيه التي
يبدو ان قادت الاحزاب والكتل الاحترافيه
ال- ال-
الحكومه التي بدات تتشكل يقدمونها كشر همم
الانضمام الى هذه الحكومه وتتمثل في
الحقائب الوزاريه والمناصب التي يطالبون
بها بمعنى ان
الحيلوله التي
تنتقل في وجه تشكيل هذه الحكومه هو
المناصب ومحاوله ابتزاز هذه الاحزاب لبني
يمين ثانيه اياهم من اجل حصول كل حزب على
ما يسعى اليه في تشكيل هذه الحكومه علما
بان قبيله طلب تمديد المهله من قبلنا
تنياهو كان قد اعلن عن توصله الى اتفاق مع
حزب شاس وقبلها مع بن جرير وبطبيعه الحال
هناك في الطريق التوصل الى او اتمام
الاتفاق مع سمواتردش وبعد الاحزاب الاخرى
ولكن بطبيعه الحال الصراع حتى هذه اللحظه
كما يرد في كتاب نتانه يتمثل بالتنافس على
المناصب والحصول على المكاسب قبيل
الانطلاق هذه الحكومه وما الذي يحدث ليله
في حال فشلنا اياها في تشكيل الحكومه بعد
بعد انتهاء هذه المهوله الجديده
يعني في حل استنف ده نتنياهو العشره ايام
ولم يتمكن حتى منتصف الليل السابع
والعشرين من هذا الشهر الاربعاء القادم
عندها سيعود الى الرئيس اسحاق خير سوق
سيبلغه بانه سيعيد التكليف اليه وبانه فشل
في تشكيل هذه الحكومه بعد منحه الاضافيه
حينها ستعود الكره الى ملعب الرئيس
الاسرائيلي من اجل تكليف شخصيه اخرى او
بمساله كان هناك امكانيه ايضا ان يكون
اعاده هذه القضيه الى الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
ولكن في الاغلب سيكلف الرئيس
باختيار شخصيه من اجل تكليف هذه الحكومه
او ان تكون هناك انتخابات سادسه شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه